Amherst College has released an
Orwellian common language guide to
police students speech on campus we will
examine the most perverse definitions as
well as the left's obsession with
language then Portland State pushes
speech codes
studies show that trigger warnings are
absolutely useless and Cambridge
disinvites Jordan Peterson what do all
of these episodes tell us about the
modern left we will explore I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Doyle show
[Music]
oh man I think that what these colleges
are doing today is basically covering
for those rich parents who bought their
kids way into school because there that
was the big scandal that was the biggest
scandal in higher education ever
concerning elite universities until
about five minutes later when these
universities again and again speech
codes common language guides this is
really perverse this was so bad that the
head of the university and the head of
the office of diversity and inclusion at
Amherst both had to issue apologies both
had to pull away
this guide luckily we have screenshots
so we can read the definitions because
this was no accident what this was is
being described as a gasps you know you
hear politicians have a gaffe and what a
gaffe is supposed to be is when you
mistakenly say something you didn't mean
in reality what a gaffe is is when you
say exactly what you mean but it's not
received well and you weren't supposed
to say it and you were trying to be more
deceptive that's exactly what's
happening here this is all for a purpose
this ties into the trigger warnings this
ties into disinviting jordan peterson
we'll get to all of that but first let's
make a little money honey with ring
speaking of safe spaces you should
actually have a safe space and rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
you probably already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you know those kind of surprise visitors
who show up in the middle of the night
want to take all your belongings you
will get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone this is thanks to the HD video and
two-way audio features on ring devices
or producer just the other day senior
producer Jonathan hey he gets woken up
at 3:00 in the morning he's lying in his
bed with his wife and there are these
two drug addled wackos who were at his
door who were clearly just trying to see
if anybody was home and if no one was
home I don't know what would have
happened would they've broken in well
fortunately for Jonathan he has a ring
because we're big ring fans here at the
Daily wire so he was able to talk to
them right away immediately they said
okay all right we're gonna leave we're
gonna hey okay we're a no big deal right
of course he could have been on a beach
in Boca he could have been at the office
or he could have been in his bedroom
which he was it's a
amazing technology it's unbelievably
inexpensive for the value check it out
right now you'll have a special offer on
a ring starter kit available that is
with a video doorbell and motion
activated floodlight cam the starter kit
has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home go to ring comm slash Knolls kano
wles ring.com slash Knolls now we move
from home security to safe spaces on
campus this guide the common language
guide was sent out by Amherst University
now wasn't sent out by the language
departments wasn't sent out by the
English department you know Amherst has
a good English program you think may be
a guide on language would be sent out by
them no no no no no it wasn't even sent
out by the Office of the President or
the office of the Dean of Students it
was sent out by the office of inclusion
and diversity this is something out of
1984 this is something right out of
George Orwell to hear things like the
office of inclusion and diversity what
what does that office do what is the
purpose of that campuses are quite
diverse they've been very diverse for a
very long time they are inclusive it's a
university that's the point of inclusion
I guess they're not inclusive to all of
the conservative speakers that they
disinvite but the office of inclusion
and diversity is very often leading the
charge to disinvite those people so what
do they do they send out orwellian
guides like this they police people's
language they enforce speech codes they
try to stop the free expression of ideas
they try to enforce a leftist ideology
and a leftist orthodoxy so this is how
they described it they said quote this
project emerged out of a need to come to
a common and shared understanding of
language in order to foster
opportunities for community building and
effective communication within and
across difference it includes a list of
carefully researched and thoughtfully
discussed definitions for key diversity
and inclusion terms so right here you
know you know immediately that today
there excuse that this shouldn't have
been sent out it was a mistake oh they
didn't mean
blah blah you know that's not true they
say in their first letter these are
carefully researched these have been
thoughtfully discussed this is a very
very intentional they tell you twice in
one sentence that it's highly
intentional and the purpose of this is
is very good ostensibly the the nominal
purpose what they say is we need a
shared understanding of language in
order to foster opportunities for
community building now the purpose of
language is to communicate right that's
the most basic definition of language I
have my own subjective experience going
on in my head
you have your own subjective experience
going on in your head and the only way
that we can bridge that unbridgeable gap
is through language what is language
it's letters and words and sounds which
all of which are symbols to represent
ideas that are outside of both of us
so I look at a tree and I see the tree
and it's got leaves and it's got
branches and it's got a trunk okay and I
want to communicate the idea of a tree
to you how do we do that you have your
own perception of the tree as well but
unless we have a common word for the
common experience in objective reality
of the tree then we can't communicate
that's the purpose of language you don't
need an office of diversity and
inclusion to have language the English
language is much older than the Amherst
College office of diversity and
inclusion so they say their purpose is
to foster opportunities for
communication no no no no no we have
words we have a language what their real
purpose is is to rewrite language to
totally change language to create new
terms that connote new ideological
constructs so that they can shape the
ideology and the orthodoxy on campus so
just an example what is capitalism we
know what capitalism right we know it's
we did a whole episode on it the other
day basically it boils down to private
property and people producing and
exchanging private property and
governments
the rights of private property basically
what it comes down to
even the term capitalism is basically
just invented and and propagated by
Marxists so even then it's kind of a
loaded term but that's basically what it
means here is how Amherst's diversity
and inclusion office defines capitalism
as a quote economic and political system
in which a country's trade and Industry
are controlled by private owners for
profit rather than the state okay yeah
basically I'm good with that then they
go on this system leads to exploitative
labor practices which affect
marginalized groups disproportionately
hold on a second I thought this was a
dictionary I thought this was a guide to
language I thought this was just a
common language so we know we're using
the same terms so what they do is
they'll take a term and maybe they'll
even define it accurately and then
they'll redefine it so the first
sentence is right the second sentence is
their ideological redefinition of that
word and by the way in the whole guide
sometimes they don't even start with a
real definition very often they just
start with the ideology they define
legal and illegal you would think that
this is a fairly basic thing legal and
illegal quote a highly racialized term
all right we can stop right there
what how is legal and illegal a highly
racialized term legal means lawful and
illegal means unlawful or criminal there
is no etymological or historical or
philosophical or any connection to race
whatsoever but that's how it begins a
highly racialized term to describe a
person's presence in a nation without
government-issued immigration status
first of all what other immigration
status is there if not government-issued
is it issued by Johnny down the street
okay the government says you're not an
immigrant to this country you're not a
legal immigrant but Johnny says you are
so in that case your illegal immigrant
right
who else would determine immigration
status but the civil authority of course
this is absurd now you
the definition goes on this is not an
appropriate noun or adjective to
describe an individual not appropriate
says who says you because you're
policing our language often misused to
designate certain undocumented members
of a society specifically people of
color we okay to deny their
contributions right to exist and
recognition as people within certain
national boundaries
well it doesn't undermine the right to
exist the people are allowed to exist I
suppose it does undermine their right to
exist within certain national boundaries
because there are such things as
immigration laws so what this says is
that if you use the words legal or
illegal you are buying into a highly
racist bigoted awful premise that
nations should be allowed to control
their own immigration what this
definition does is outlaws as a matter
of speech on campus anything other than
an open borders ideology which denies
the nation-state entirely that's just
the second one about assimilation this
is a related concept assimilation we
know assimilation means you go to a new
place and you behave like the locals by
easy cave I was on zakat Ravi's what
they say in in Italy which is translated
roughly or translated idiomatically to
when in Rome do as the Romans do this is
what assimilation is when I go to Italy
what do I do I wear my nice pair sole
sunglasses and I sip on you know Lavazza
coffee or what I just do things that
Italians do sometimes I do that here as
well but that's because I'm of Italian
heritage if I go to Britain I'm gonna
behave differently if I go to the Middle
East I'm gonna behave a little
differently that's assimilation and
certainly when you immigrate somewhere
assimilation really matters because
you're gonna live there you want to be
part of that community this is how
Amherst College defines it assimilation
happens quote as a response to forms of
oppression including but not limited to
xenophobia racism this had two row
normativity and religious of
pression among other types of oppression
if you choose to enter another country
and immigrate to that country and live
in that country for 30 years you're not
doing it because you're oppressed if
that's oppressive you can always go home
you should go home you're you're asking
to do that you're volunteering to do
that there's nothing oppressive then
about the people wanting you to I don't
know speak their language follow their
laws behave a little more like they do
then only how you want to behave but
they invert that what what is more
oppressive invading a foreign country
and living there and living off of their
welfare and violating their laws and
forcing everybody not only to
accommodate but celebrate you is that
more oppressive or is it oppressive to
say hey if you want to come to the
greatest country on earth and we're
gonna let you stay even though you broke
our laws maybe speak English which do
you think is more oppressive they define
oppression by the way oppression is
predicated upon access to institutional
power Oh see this is how they're gonna
tell me that only big bad straight white
men who think that they're men they're
the only ones who can be oppressive so
you can't be oppressive if you invade
somebody's country take all their
welfare violate their laws and force
everyone to celebrate you that that's
that's not oppressive because it's
predicated upon access to institutional
power marginalized communities do not
have access to institutional power so it
says women can be as prejudiced as men
but women cannot be just as sexist as
men because they do not hold political
economic and institutional power of
course this is nonsense
let's take one institution the
institution that sent out this guide
Amherst College at American universities
women constitute the majority of
students not even that slim majority
they got they got a few points on men so
actually they do have institutional
power specifically at the institution
that is claiming that they don't how
about political power in the United
States women have the right to vote
there are more women in the United
States than men more importantly there
are many more women
voters than men voters women have about
a 15-point voter gap on men so actually
if we're talking about institutional
political power women have way more
political power in the United States
than men do just using their own
definitions but it doesn't matter what
they need to do is not just define the
word but then have that little explainer
line afterward women cannot be just as
sexist as men marginalized communities
do not have access to institutional
power but they do so what happens if
they do I guess what it means is they're
not that marginalized they're they're
really not very marginalized communities
and then this brings us to American
exceptionalism this is an historical
philosophical political linguistic
construct that ostensibly a good
University completely misunderstands
before we get to that let's make a
little money honey with honey you know
how much I love honey honey is the only
way to buy stuff online have you ever
bought something online and you missed a
discount discount came up a day later or
you missed it on a certain website
I have not shopped without honey online
for years since before the daily wire
existed I am a true believer it's a free
browser app or a free browser add-on
rather that will find you the best deals
online it finds discounts and coupons
across 37,000 web sites Amazon Sephora
Best Buy Nordstrom more it is basically
free money that's all this is well I you
know they always ask what was the last
thing I bought on honey I always say I
don't what was the last thing I didn't
buy on honey I don't think I've made a
purchase without honey in years lastly
here's a good example last night I just
wanted to buy a tie I needed to get a
new tie figured I'm looking a little too
casual and ties can range in price from
$100 a tie to 20 dollars a tie or
something like that and so I sought I
really like just like a hundred bucks
yeah but I don't want to spend that kind
of money and then just do Peduto funds
there but but and it finds saved me like
60% or something like that make sure you
use honey honey has saved it's ten
million members an average of 28 dollars
and 61 cents that's over 10 million
people tell you it saved me over a
thousand dollars certain
probably much more than that honey
members have already saved more than 800
million dollars total not bad for
something that's completely free and
takes just two clicks to install has
over a hundred thousand five-star
reviews from the google chrome store
Time magazine calls honey basically free
money I call it that too no reason not
to try it it's free to use easy to
install takes just two clicks shop with
confidence get honey for free and join
honey calm slash cough fa ce o-- v fe fe
that's join honey dot-com slash cough fa
c OV e fe fe honey the smart shopping
assistant that saves you time and money
when you're shopping on line okay
american exceptionalism this is how
amherst defines it a belief in the
superiority rightful leadership and
special moral status of the United
States and its people originally
grounded in the 17th century Puritan in
Protestant religious culture so this you
see how they start right away a belief
in the superiority now the reason that
they go for that is because the word
exceptional is is misused and and
misunderstood especially by illiterates
like the people at the office of
inclusion and diversity and Amherst
University we think of exceptional as
excellent or superlative or the just the
best thing ever
exceptional refers to exceptions
deviation from the norm and America is
certainly an exceptional country it's
unlike other countries it was fed from
it's very beginning it was founded and
developed differently than the old world
that's why it's the new world it was
founded by it was discovered by
Christopher Columbus a devout Christian
greatest navigator of his age it was
obviously founded by pilgrims at
Plymouth it was founded by people at
Jamestown who wanted a better life was
it was founded by people who basically
were not of the aristocracy they were
not entrenched in the old world there
was a new beginning here there were
traditions that they brought with them
there was a culture there was a religion
that they brought with them but it
developed different man
developed little separately from the
rest of the world it then fired the shot
heard around the world
it launched perhaps in the history of
the world the only conservative
revolution wasn't a radical leftist
revolution like the French Revolution it
was a conservative revolution and so
much as there can be one it conserved
those traditions it's been a beacon of
Liberty for the rest of the world that's
an exception that's why the United
States has a unique role in the world
it's not necessarily to say superior you
know every into always but that's what
they say because they want to denigrate
that idea by misrepresenting it and then
they have oh my gosh the white Savior
complex have you ever heard of this this
is a new term so they're not just
redefining other terms like American
exceptionalism they're introducing new
ideological terms American
exceptionalism or a white Savior complex
an attitude or posture of condescending
benevolence based on the idea that white
people inherently should are in a
position to and are qualified to save
people of color this can be seen
internationally as well as domestically
see Eurocentrism and American
exceptionalism so this term with this
term is actually talking about is that
Western culture developed beyond any
other culture in the history of the
world religiously politically
technologically I mean the obvious one
is technologically because the West
broadly invented every single thing
that's ever been invented but and made
virtually every discovery that has ever
been discovered but politically this is
true as well look around the rest of the
world sub-saharan Africa the Middle East
Asia pre-columbian American systems of
government do those systems of
government protect the rights of
minorities no do those systems of
government treat women in a particularly
nice way no do those systems of
government protect Liberty in an
individual and family based and
community relevant sense no do what do
those are those cultures have they very
often delved into tyrannies that are
make life short and brutish and
miserable yes I'm just talking about
politically and so what they're saying
is how dare you say that Western culture
is better than other cultures we're
going to accuse that statement of being
racist so you see what they do they're
saying to use the term Western is so
wrong you you have to you're really
talking about whiteness that white
people are better than brown people
that's not what it's saying at all
well also this is again just another
evidence of these people's ignorance
when you think about the great figures
in in history in Western history or they
all blond-haired blue-eyed guys I don't
think that's true too one example I
think of is Saint Augustine of Hippo one
of the five greatest minds in the
history of the West he was from Carthage
something tells me was a bit swarthy I'm
a bit swarthy myself I'll have you know
the discoverer of the Americas was
Italian little on the darker side as
well
but they have to paint all of the West
is this just Aryan white blond blue-eyed
racially uniform type thing because they
can't grapple with the ideas they can
trample with history so they write it
off as bigoted and then just a lot just
very briefly I have to mention the other
two terms they included they're tucking
and packing do you know what these terms
are
if you're if you're watching with a
young child please cover his ears right
now tucking is when a man really wants
to look like a woman he tucks and when a
woman really wants to look like a man
she packs this is being described in the
Amherst guide to language I mentioned it
one because it's ridiculous but two
because it shows you the lengths to
which they will go to invent new terms
to invent new language in service of
their own ideology and and gender
ideology is so central to the the left's
broader ideological agenda right now
all of this what is all of this very
very different versions of it but all
the same assault on language this
reminds me of the play Alice in
Wonderland by Alice Kirsten Berg Alison
there's a passage in Alice in Wonderland
where Alice is talking to Humpty Dumpty
Humpty Dumpty says when I use a word it
means just what I choose it to mean
neither more nor less Alice responds the
question is whether you can make words
mean different things the question is
which is to be master that's all
impenetrability that's what I say would
you tell me please what that means I
meant by impenetrability that we've had
enough of that subject and it would be
just as well if you'd mention what you
mean to do next as I suppose you don't
mean to stop here all the rest of your
life that little exchange tells you
everything you need to know about this
language battle that's going on the left
like Humpty Dumpty wants to use a word
and just have it mean whatever they say
that it means now Alice asks the
question that we're all asking can you
make words mean different things than
they mean and Humpty Dumpty asks the
real question which is to be master to
use words accurately to use words to
mean what they mean or to redefine words
altogether in the long run reality
reasserts itself but in the short run
the left knows that they can impose
their tyranny over logic over reason by
redefining the words Humpty Dumpty says
impenetrability and what does he mean by
impenetrability he says go away now go
away I'm not talking about this
he sends Alice away who's asking for
some reason that's what's happening at
even our elite universities and worst
college is considered a very good
college and this is the sort of thing
that they're putting out in
penetrability which is to be mastered
that is the question we've got a lot
more to talk about we've got to talk
about how this ties in to trigger
warnings Jordan Peterson and the mailbag
but first go over to Daly wire.com ten
a month 100 ollars for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
flavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get them out wall show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag you get to
ask questions in backstage which is
coming up you get another Kingdom and
you get a far better drinking vessel
than this I'm currently sipping out of a
mustachioed little cup in my hotel room
it's not as good you need the leftist
ears tumbler although I'm frankly I'm
afraid that before I get my flight
tomorrow and I get out of Missouri I'm
going to drown in a deluge I'm gonna
have to turn my plane ticket in for a
boat ticket make sure that you have the
leftist here's tumbler you will find
yourself inconvenienced as I am go to
daily wire comm we'll be right back with
a lot more on the mailbag
what is the point of all this language
doctoring the left would tell us that
it's just about making people
comfortable just about understanding
just know it's not either of those
things the evidence of this is the
trigger warnings another way that they
try to censor ideas is through trigger
warnings before you can encounter a
great work of literature or history or
whatever they will now offer a trigger
warning say if you're prone to
post-traumatic stress you shouldn't read
this if you've ever been an alter you
shouldn't know it's bad this would be
bad for you so there's a new study that
just came out in clinical psychological
signs showed that people who see words
with the warning or without the warning
have exactly the same reaction the
trigger warnings do nothing to alleviate
the stress of people who go on to read
them and it's actually even worse than
this there was a Harvard study that came
out last year it showed the trigger
warnings make people less resilient and
it can make reactions to triggering
materials even worse so then what's the
purpose because in an academic context
during the context of public discourse
you get the warning okay but you still
have to grapple with the material unless
the real purpose is not psychological
and not academic trigger warnings are
useless on that regard they're
politically useful because they're
really just about censorship their way
to censor ideas and a sense of great
works and a sense of great thinkers
under the radar that's what it's all
about it's it's even the case when it
comes to popular speakers so I'm not
just talking about Plato or Agustin or
whatever in a Mark Twain you know
there's a trigger warnings now on
Huckleberry Finn I'm talking about
popular modern speakers a great example
of this Jordan Peterson Jordan Peterson
was at it was offered to be a visiting
fellow at Cambridge University this
makes sense Jordan Peterson's one of the
most popular academics I mean certainly
the most popular academic of our age
this is his moment and the Cambridge
University Student Union complained they
said
he called white privilege of myth and
this was unacceptable he doubted the
scientific consensus on climate change
he claimed that ming men can be victims
of gender oppression and he argued that
the patriarchy is predicated on
competence this is unacceptable they
have to censor Jordan now though take
away from this is profound for
conservatives because I think there are
a lot of conservatives who think hey if
I'm just kind of squishy
if I'm just one of the nice guys if I'm
just moderate then the Left won't censor
me okay they can go after Donald Trump
they can go after whoever Jeanine Pirro
what would any of the people who are
under fire and that's I didn't go after
them they'll never come after me I'm so
reasonable I'm so moderate doesn't
matter the left doesn't go after you
because of how conservative you are they
go after you because of how prominent
you are Jordan Peterson is not that
conservative I like the guy I've always
enjoyed talking to him we had a cigar
with him you know a few months ago I
enjoy talking to him he's not some
rock-ribbed right winger he wasn't you
know wearing Brooks Brothers ties during
the Reagan Revolution I don't think he
dares to contradict certain leftist
orthodoxy and he's a very very prominent
if he were less prominent they wouldn't
worry as much about censoring him if
other people were more prominent they'd
go after them that's what it's about
it's not about the ideas it's about
brute power I have to show you this by
the way before we get to the mailbag
today I was over in Michigan with Ben
and well we had a good time there were
all these planned protests and so I got
to talk to some of the people out there
on the street they were holding big
signs that said trans women are women
and Shapiro's a white supremacist and
all that kind of stuff we just cut
together a quick little clip take a look
from my little field trip to Michigan
then we'll get to the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles we're here at the
University of Michigan Ann Arbor because
Ben Shapiro is speaking tonight this is
caused mayhem protests counter events we
are gonna speak to students to see what
they think there are a lot of protests
planned yeah what's that about oh I
don't know I guess Ben is just so scary
I mean he's like me a five foot nothing
Jew that is been Shapiro's face on a
naked male body excuse me hello you're
here to protest that guy well what were
you with you said you say that he has
been a lot that is the closest I've ever
been to Ben Shapiro's naked body and I
don't need any more of it what don't you
like about Ben Shapiro he's pretty much
what's wrong with this country
trans women are women so should trans
women be allowed to compete in women's
sports they're women
doesn't that obliterate the very
category of women's sports no if they
are truly women then how is that any
different than someone like say Rachel
Dolezal who is a white person who
identifies as a black person
I don't have the answer trans women are
women it's like if a trans woman has a
penis is that a biologically female
penis yes there's there's female PMS
it's are they're male uterus absolutely
what are they so afraid of why can't
they just go listen to Ben's talk and
then they can do their own talk later I
mean that's how you really make progress
we're hoping that we get some people
that come and actually listen and
actually try and challenge their own
views and would you like to not a chance
would you like - I don't do media all
right they want to stand they want a
protest they want to hold up signs but
they don't want to explain what the
signs mean we're here because we really
care about the issues a lot I make sure
things are getting done about well I
think what you're doing God's work at
you thank you very much you say
pineapples don't care about your
feelings yeah a lot of people put it on
pizza and they get really confused and
stuff and there's some of its debate
about pineapples but they don't really
care about our feelings about whether it
on pizza a white supremacist
[Applause]
[Music]
there is so much more to that I mean
there were some of them though it was so
screechie that you couldn't even use the
audio but they I understand why they
don't want to engage in any sort of
discussion like there was one woman I
asked her I said you know doesn't that
doesn't transgender ideology obliterate
the category of women if men are
basically just defining womanhood
however they want according to whatever
drag-queen caricature they want and she
said oh yeah that's your gotcha question
it's it's not a gotcha question it's a
very basic question given your premise
and you can't answer it they can't
answer it so they want to jump around in
signs and wear it
weird-looking masks but that's mine
can't wait to go meet some more of them
out on the street let's get to the
mailbag first question from Troy hey
Michael
what do you think would happen if the
Democratic Party - the Democratic Party
if a black Republican presidential
candidate ran for office how would this
play into the left side entity politics
Thanks Kennedy hashtag came for Ben
stayed for Michael it wouldn't matter at
all they would call us racist that's
what would happen they could nominate
the oldest whitest straightest most
manly guy in the world
probably not the most manly guy if we're
talking about that I'm just saying the
Democratic nomination not that's
probably not gonna happen but they could
nominate the whitest person ever we
could nominate Wesley Snipes to be the
Republican nominee for president they
would call us racist they do this anyway
and they call black people who are
conservative Uncle Tom's they do this to
Clarence Thomas we have a black Supreme
Court justice one of the greatest
justices in the history of the court
probably the most conservative justice
in the history of the court and they say
he's an idiot he's a race traitor or he
that's all they do they would do it to
us as well they do this to women they
say Republicans are sexist say you know
we nominated a woman for vice-president
in 2008 we have we had a female
presidential candidate in 2016 we have a
ton of women serving in top roles in the
trump administration first woman ever to
win a presidential campaign as the
campaign manager Kellyanne Conway what
did they do for her
all they do is is promote her husband
saying rude and awful things about her
and her boss so wouldn't matter at all
you're you're assuming that logic would
play some role in the left's attacks on
the right it's not the left's attacks on
the right or not because of logic or
because of ideas it's all about tearing
down tradition and and conservative
thought and so they're gonna do it
anyway even if it doesn't make sense
from Stan how you doing Mike I know you
and sweet little ol and Lisa are happily
married but hypothetically if she were
to be unfaithful to you how would you
handle the situation is adultery a good
enough reason to divorce someone even if
they did it once I know the Bible says
till death do us part but I think the
cheating is a horrible Act I asked Ben
the same question a couple weeks ago he
said he'd stay with his wife for the
sake of the kids but I want to know your
thoughts thanks love to show divorce is
not permissible that's the beginning and
end of it divorce is not permissible in
the case of emotional or physical abuse
a separation could be permissible or
even morally obligatory or a civil
divorce could be obligatory but this
does not dissolve the sacramental union
of marriage now in some cases annulment
recognizes not divorce but that a
marriage was never legitimate in the
first place if you find out you know
you're married to your wife for 30 years
and you find out she's your sister
that's not a legitimate marriage and so
that marriage would be annulled there is
no exception to this rule for adultery
some people I think want to argue that
that in the Gospels Christ makes an
exception for adultery those arguments
are extraordinarily weak and create a
lot of perverse moral incentives there's
there's really not a lot of evidence for
that so I would think that at my best
I would probably throw the guy out of
window I want that would that wouldn't
be me at my best
but that would certainly be what I would
want to do but I like to think of my
best I would never get a divorce I'm
pretty pretty
forceful on them now that's a horrible
thing of your wife cheats on you it it's
it's really hard to especially because
typically it's men who stray because men
very often think with organs that they
shouldn't be thinking with more so than
women do and so it is a different
situation when a man cheats on his wife
and when a woman cheats on her husband
they're both horrific for a marriage but
you're even talking about the less
common version so it's incredibly hard I
don't know how I would react in that
situation I don't know how I would get
over it I don't know how I would react
to it but it's not a legitimate cause
for divorce no sorry
well maybe that's a good thing I think
it's a good thing from Nicholas dear
Knowles my older brother refers to you
as daddy Knowles what do you think about
this I love it when they call me big
papa and I only smoke stoves when they
roll prop bah that's what I think from
Christian dear sir I am a pretty good
Christian but I admit that a vice of
mine is that I like to listen to and
partake in edgy or comedy like Adam
Carolla and Gavin McGinnis I know it is
not the most wholesome comedy but I find
them very funny and I do not think this
causes me to sin can I keep listening
very respectfully Christian yeah of
course that's not a sin it's not a sin
to listen to dirty comics come on both
of those guys are very funny no that's
not at all but we've really broadened
the definition of vice and sin if we
think that listening to the Adam Carolla
podcast is a sin now you might be
wasting time or you might be being lazy
I guess that that could be a sin but the
comedy itself now that comedy is a nice
thing comedy is one of the consolations
of life go on enjoy the podcast make
sure every day
once you've finished listening to my
podcast you you can you're more than
welcome to go on and listen to Adam
we're Gavin from Joshua local students
in my state Bates College Michigan found
signs posted around campus that says
it's okay to be white obviously campus
officials local authorities and the
local media are freaking out over this
what are your thoughts this was a pretty
smart PR camp
pane by white racial politics activists
it's okay to be white why is this a good
campaign because nobody but a bigot
could disagree with that statement of
course it's okay to be white it's not
it's not terrible to be white it's okay
to be black it's okay to be Hispanic
it's okay to be Taiwanese it's yeah it's
okay to have certain immutable physical
characteristics now what are the signs
imply what the signs are trying to do is
something that racial activists have
tried to do for a long time which is
raise a white racial consciousness in
some ways this reaction should be
totally expected the columnist Sam
Francis predicted this he's sort of
called for it which is that if the left
is going to embrace racial politics for
every other racial group then it and and
by the way if those racial groups are
going to categorize whiteness as a
legitimate category if those rate
intersectional politics people will say
whiteness is a racial category then it
makes perfect sense that the people that
they are criticizing and attacking for
being white or going to have a white
racial consciousness themselves it's
like my friend mr. Clavin always says
bigotry turns the other person into what
you say they are so even I think there
there could be a legitimate critique of
whiteness per se because perhaps the
differences between Italians and
Irishmen are a legitimate or distinct or
profound and maybe to classify them as
one race is is painting with too broad a
brush however because the left has
embraced racial identity politics there
is now a white racial consciousness some
people think this is the only way
forward to preserve Western civilization
I think that's total bunk and I think
it's mistaking the court for the horse
and the tail wagging the dog the
foundation of Western civilization is
not physical it's not a physical trait
it's not even cultural it's not
certainly not political it's
religious Hilaire Belloc said Europe is
the faith and the faith is Europe that
is what creates Western civilization is
Christianity the faith from there
because politic because culture is
downstream of religion because culture
is downstream of the cult you get
Western culture and from there you get
Western politics and from there as the
West came into Geographic form and
expanded to other places you get certain
racial characteristics but I I think
it's really backwards and and it's an
easy mistake to make but it's one that
all of these race racial politics guys
make certainly on the left but on the
right to from Tony hi Michael do you
think AOC has a legitimate chance in
2024 to win the primary or general
election I thought she was a guarantee
for the primary until recent polling
shows a dip in approval how do you see
the trend moving from here thanks love
the show she's very good at getting
attention but she's only gotten
attention now for six months she hasn't
been in the public eye for very long
we're gonna see if she flames out or if
she has staying power Donald Trump is
also good at getting attention and he
has consistently gotten attention for 40
years which is why he was a more
legitimate pop culture candidate than
aoc or somebody like that she will be 35
before Election Day in 2024 meaning she
could she I guess she could be elected
it would make her certainly the youngest
president in American history so the
likelihood that she goes anywhere I'm
not so sure and she's just so ignorant
and she's so bad when she's not reading
scripted remarks that something tells me
if she got onto a Miss a debate stage
she would be blown out of the water even
with a radicalized Democrat party but
we'll have to wait and see from Sheamus
hi Michael I recently heard the argument
that the fusing of fiscal and social
conservatism within the same political
movement is incoherent as fiscal
conservatism and capitalism are not
philosophically connected to the
preservation of traditional social
values how would you respond to this
claim well we're using very broad terms
however I don't really buy that premise
because if we're talking about fiscal
conservatism as globalized free markets
with no tariffs whatsoever and no
thought to American workers and no
thought to American industry then yeah
I'm not so sure that that makes a whole
lot of sense with social conservatism or
traditionalism however if we're talking
about fiscal conservatism as protecting
private property then that's quite
conservative we're talking about it as
lower tax rates lower property tax rates
especially less corporatism less
cronyism yeah I think that has a whole
lot to do with social conservatism it is
certainly the case that when you have
long-standing landed property two
interests that keep their own property
that is going to be a great bulwark
against radical social change in radical
social evolution when you have a system
that recognizes private property rights
as a moral imperative rather than just
some sort of efficient utilitarian
economic design then you have a very
good bulwark against radical social
engineering and revolution so in that
case I think there is a very good
argument for fiscal conservatism and
social conservatism you just have to be
careful to define fiscal conservatism
and not simply equate it with some open
borders a constant open trade of
libertarianism basically because those
are not the same thing okay that's our
show I'm in Missouri at an item of a
giving a speech at Truman State
University so if you're in Kirksville
Missouri swing on by come on by just a
quick three-hour drive from the Kansas
City Airport otherwise I will see you on
Monday in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jesuit of era production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19